only set the rules and then broke them
but has repeatedly lied to the british
public about it
sheila
vara this is
a key point isn't it and it's one that
the opposition have made much of that
whilst the staff are number 10 are
embroiled in in working out what
happened with these parties and
furnishing sue gray's requirements it is
it does mean that other stuff is going
by the wayside
well jane you make a very good point and
frankly the government has been very
keen to talk about other important
issues cost of living the price of
energy uh the fact we've got a hundred
thousand troops uh on the russian
ukrainian border uh but i'm afraid uh
notwithstanding what louise has just
said it is actually labour and lib dems
who wish to carry on with this debate in
fact only yesterday uh labour's deputy
leader angela rainer um called an urgent
question and took up almost an hour in
parliament uh talking about this very
issue when uh the prime minister
subsequently came along and for an hour
we're speaking about uh the situation in
russia and uh those troops on the
ukrainian border uh very important
issues to be dealt with and i think
that's where our attention should be as
far as the uh report is concerned well
you know it won't be long now a matter
of hours before subray's report uh is
published and then i hope that we can
draw a line and really deal with those
very important issues that concern my
constituents and millions of people
throughout the country uh as i say there
are important issues there but can i
also say jane that i think it's
important that we recognize the
enormously difficult decisions that the
prime minister has taken and which have
been the right decisions uh at the start
of this pandemic there was no job of the
prime
it is but in terms of criticism i think
we need to recognize uh that he has made
the right call on a number of issues for
example uh at uh christmas he made the
right call in terms of the uh security
measures that were required and the
restrictions uh we've managed to the
situation right now is that there are
more people in work than before the
pandemic and there are more vacancies
available than before the pandemic and
the second we are the largest the
fastest growing economy in the g7 and i
think that needs to be taken into
account okay let's bring in christie
john and you were raising your eyebrows
there when uh he was suggesting that the
opposition are making too much uh of
what has happened in downing street i
mean is that the case are we and the
media as well guilty of focusing too
much on on our party that happened a
couple of years ago then the really
important stuff
we are not the ones who have done
anything wrong we are not the ones whose
behavior has been questioned we are not
the people in 10 downing street who
showed absolutely no respect for the
public showed actually contempt for the
very rules that they had said and you
know the government can dance in the
head of a pin for as long as it wants
but that is the problem that's why we're
not able to focus on the issues of the
potential war in ukraine of the the
energy crisis the cost of living crisis
the inflation it's not the opposition's
fault it's not the media's fault it's
the prime minister's fault and the prime
minister i mean as one of my colleagues
pointed out he seems to spend like
spending time in his garden so maybe he
should be in gardening leave until this
has got to the bottom of and we have
someone in downing street who can focus
and the country can focus on the issues
rather than one errant
person's um bad behavior and disrespect
for the rules that they set for others
but didn't follow themselves
louise hogan what what to shaylish's
point there that that it is the
opposition who's going on about this i
mean this is a bit of a gift for labor
isn't it really the longer this drags on
the more boris johnson's uh name is
dragged through the mud the better it is
for the labour party and as he said uh
it took up an hour of parliamentary time
discussing it
i yesterday it really demonstrates the
mess that the party are in that now
which at the point where tory mps are
being wheeled out to defend the prime
minister and pretending that the prime
minister and downing street being under
criminal investigation by the
metropolitan police doesn't merit
scrutiny in parliament that isn't a
serious issue
the prime minister faces serious
questions the public understand the
truth and that's the danger for the tory
parties that the public see this they
see that the man who set the rules
required the country to follow them
required them to take unimaginable
decisions and sacrifices was flouting
those rules um repeatedly
in whitehall
and in in total contempt of the british
public and then he lied repeatedly about
them the idea that the metropolitan
police investigating that doesn't
warrant being raised in parliament is
absolutely riseable okay we're going to
leave it there because we're out of time
i'm afraid but louise hague and shayla
shvara and christine jardin thank you
all so much for joining us today
well our deputy political editor sam
coates is with me now um sam you've got
your ear close to the ground boris
johnson's just leaving number 10.
a few shouts from the journalists there
no response from him though straight in
the car
and he'll begin that short journey from
downing street
along to the houses of parliament
as he as he makes that let's talk to sam
who's here in the studio sam coats up
what are you hearing is is it going to
be today this report that's the
million-dollar question i can't
definitively tell you uh boris johnson
has just been in downing street with
quite a lot of his sort of closest
aides he's got now a sort of inner core
kitchen cabinet people have been with
him a long time figures like conor burns
and others that are doing the heavy
lifting of trying to rescue his uh
political reputation come what may in
the coming hours and they're the team
immediately around him just at the
moment
um but we're all waiting as we have been
for so many days now for the sue grey
report here's what we know it's
basically complete it is up to sue grey
when it gets published and it is up to
boris johnson what gets published now
that might sound confusing
but it feels to me like
having had months and months of downing
streets saying the whole thing is going
to go in the public domain the whole
report is going to go into the public
day and this morning there are signs
inside government that the prime
minister still has two i'm being told
from inside government that the prime
minister is still to make up his mind
that that is definitively the case
could this be linked to the fact that
sue gray hasn't
published it or given it to pr to
downing street for it to be published
well we're going to wait and see what
does that mean in turn that the most
important question to be asked at prime
minister's questions should kierstama
choose to ask it is prime minister will
you publish all of sue grey's report or
will you choose to withhold some of it
which is your right that goes against
your previous commitment and goes
against we understand the wishes of sue
gray that's the most important question
just at the moment are we clear whether
or not the prime minister
has or will actually see the full report
because i did read one report that said
that
the bits that sue grey is handed to the
police will not be then furnished to the
prime minister is that correct that is
correct so um forgive me there are lots
of different uh things that can come
under the heading of report she did some
work uh that would appear to suggest
evidence of criminality and what i think
we believe is eight out of the 17
different parties that she was
investigating
that evidence has been handed over
directly to the metropolitan police and
it was on the basis of that evidence
that they uh announced that they were
going to open a criminal inquiry um
now at the point that they did that sue
gray did not share that evidence with
number 10
number 10 confirmed that yesterday he
doesn't know what the potentially
criminal evidence is that the police
have which must be you know cause some
jangling of nerves inside downing street
but that is different to as it were the
sort of two bits of work uh that she's
prepared potentially to go in the public
domain the findings which will be a
relatively
considerably more limited uh set of as
it were conclusions and then the broader
report which will set out a bit more
detail of what happened when now as i
say i am being told by figures inside
government that sue grey wants to see
the whole thing publish and i'm told
it's up to the prime minister to make
that definitive decision despite
previously promising that he would we
can only speculate whether or not there
are conversations inside government
about whether or not it is wise to
withhold bits of that report talking to
cabinet ministers tory mps uh two mps on
camera in the last hour they were incred
there was incredulity at the idea that
you would withhold any of this as one
cabinet minister said to me look
the idea that you don't put this in the
public domain will only result in it
being leaked to the media hours
afterwards so there is no point in
withholding an uh uh anything so it
leads to prompts the question will why
even have this set of thoughts who knows
maybe the report is so bad that the
prime minister genuinely doesn't want to
say in the public domain knowing the
consequences that will follow
we just don't know and that is pure
speculation what i do know is that
politically
today just like yesterday boris johnson
needs to show that he's out and about
yesterday he did that statement on
ukraine today he needs to keep going
with parents questions knowing that he's
going to get a barrage of attack
of attacks because if he doesn't looks
like he's not conducting
the business of government it really is
all over
sam let's bring in uh barrister adam
wagner he's been analyzing the covert
rules throughout the pandemic um and can
give us a bit of his expertise um adam
in terms of of what we what happened
yesterday with the metropolitan police
announcing their inquiry and the
possibility of of this report
being released today does it change
anything legally
sue grey's report has no legal function
at all it's purely an internal report
you know like you would have in any
business or institution that wants to
look at something that's going on in
their organization
where the legal element comes in well i
suppose there's two places first of all
we can look at the wider facts or the
more detailed facts of these
events and make a much clearer analysis
of whether they're likely to have been
illegal or not because the law at the
time was yeah a bit complicated but you
know for example if it's clear there
were after work parties that had no work
being done at all um as is alleged
on the 18th of december for the
christmas party and the two events that
merged into one before prince philip's
funeral then
it seems like that's quite obviously
illegal we could probably predict what
police are going to find
and the other legal aspect is that the
sugue has as was
in her terms of reference handed over
material that she thinks potentially
gives rise to criminal suspicion or you
know a criminal offence so once the
material is handed over to the police
they can do what they will with it um
which is why they've launched this
investigation
is there um in terms of of actually
looking at what rules there were and
which rules could or couldn't have been
broken it is part of the issue that
in terms of work regulations and what
you were and weren't allowed to do at
work
that was classed as guidance
and and the rules about
gatherings and and meetings were were
stronger worded legally is that part of
the issue that there's a sort of slight
fudge over which particular part of the
covert regulations or guidelines it fell
under
well there was always a bit of confusion
over law and guidance throughout the
pandemic and the government were never
particularly clear over which they were
talking about at any given time and i
don't think actually many politicians
really understood the difference
but
the key thing to think about throughout
the whole pandemic is when gatherings
were banned and whether when it was when
leaving the home or being outside the
home was backed
we're looking here at whether what was
happening was reasonably necessary for
work that was the that was the key
and and as you say what there was lots
of workplace guidance for example the
guidance on the 18th of december 2020
that said you must not have a christmas
party which wasn't part of the law and a
question
for the police will be well if the
government
has released guidance for everybody else
saying things like you must not have a
christmas party
can we assume that's their view and what
is reasonably necessary for work as in
you know would it how could it be both
be reasonably necessary for work to have
a christmas christmas party when there
is guidance that you have released
yourself which says you mustn't have a
christmas party and i actually think in
these situations the guidance may be
quite useful to understand what the
government thought was reasonably
necessary for work but there'll be some
instances where it's quite obvious that
you know for example a birthday party is
not reasonably necessary for work
whatever work you're doing
and in terms of the police's operation
how easy do you think it will be to
retrospectively investigate this given
that sue gray has done all the leg work
and that that she'll be providing them
with an enormous amount of information
are they going to have to go over and
re-look at that information or will they
just accept what they're given
no they'll you know if
sue gray's work will be based in
significant part on interviews she's
done with staff
and
and politicians um the police if the
police can't just rely on those
interviews they will have to do the
interviews themselves and particularly
if they're going to be interviewing
suspects or people who potentially are
going to reveal illegal activity
in their interviews they'll have to be
interviewed under caution which is why
they can't use the sugre interviews and
in fact you know it really shows why the
police should have been
should have just done this investigation
themselves from december rather than
this odd choreography of waiting for sue
gray and then having to go and do it all
again
potentially giving people the chance to
delete emails and text messages and also
change their story
in terms of what the police may do if
they may interview boris johnson what
would be the difference between being
interviewed as a formal suspect or as a
witness
well if he's a witness he won't
necessarily have to be interviewed under
caution um but if he's somebody who
you know if we look at for example the
20th of may gathering in the garden the
bring your own boots we know he attended
that but we but he was in his own garden
so it's it's not likely that he would be
uh suspected of a criminal offense
because at the time you um this was all
about being outside of the home without
a reasonable excuse
but um the event on the 18th of june his
birthday party that was you know took
place in a in a room pre-arranged with
food and cake and all of that
he would potentially be suspected of a
criminal offence i think if he's
interviewed about that gathering if
they're looking at it then he would have
to be interviewed under caution um and
what it means is he'd have access he
potentially have access to a lawyer if
he wants one um the you know that he'd
be given uh he'd be read his rights as
you might see from you know line of duty
and those kind of tv programs
and it's a much more formal process the
whole point is that you're being
cautioned that you may have committed a
criminal offence
however
a criminal offence he may or may not
have committed but if he's given a fixed
penalty notice it doesn't lead to a
criminal record
that's correct i mean it's a um the
whole point of a fixed penalty notice is
that it does it instead of being charged
with a criminal offence um it can show
up i think on an enhanced check
but i mean
you know the the question then it
becomes really in terms of seriousness
it becomes a political question because
you might you could only be given a
fixed penalty notice under these
regulations if you if a police officer
reasonably suspects you have committed a
criminal offense um and that's a very
very serious thing for the prime
minister um to be accused of and to be
given and any public official really i
mean these were the
the people who were setting the rules i
don't just mean you know generally the
government the cabinet office is where
the rules were made it's who made the
rules you know on a daily basis they
were the ones who were deciding what how
to restrict people so i think there is
it is really serious um
whether it's a fixed penalty notice or a
criminal charge
okay adam thanks so much for now uh
adam's going to be helping us out if we
get any developments on this throughout
the day but what do some of members of
the prime minister's party think
grassroots conservative voters and
campaigners let's bring in claire
pearcel she's a former conservative
advisor and the conservative councillor
uh also joined by barry legg who is a
former tory mp uh great to talk to you
both thanks so much for joining us
claire really interesting to know what
people are saying in the constituencies
when you have your constituency meetings
what is the general feeling about what
has happened over the last few months at
number 10
there is an enormous amount of anger
going on especially when you consider
that throughout the pandemic
my residents were abiding by the rules
and they were taking part in voluntary
schemes to help the elderly to help the
vulnerable and just taking care of
themselves and their families so to
understand that the prime minister and
his staff were having parties with
suitcases of booze it just be is beyond
the pale
barry legg is is that mirrored in the
people that you are speaking to where
where you are
um i think there is some concern
about parties etc you know we all went
through a pretty difficult time over
covered most people tried to uh abide by
the rules as best they could but i think
there's also a sense that there are some
very big other issues now in the balance
the economy has to stage a substantial
recovery uh we're facing rising
inflation
rising tax
payments
and i think what we
more than anything else need is a very
steady hand on the tiller
and we need to show that we have a
conservative prime minister
that
is is in charge and can effectively
implement his policies and i think that
may involve some policy changes if he is
to survive
i mean do you think he is a steady hand
on the tiller claire um i mean we've got
the local elections coming up how how
are people in your your constituency
claire do you think going to react
i mean i'm quite lucky to not have any
local elections coming up directly in my
area but i think yes we need a steady
hand on the tiller but that is something
that we plainly don't have you have
government ministers going out to defend
this and actually just make the
situation worse as we saw from last
night we're being ambushed by a cake i
mean that is the stuff of memes which
are all going around the internet and i
think the public are now looking at us
as if to say what is it that you are
doing you seem to be fighting internally
and not taking part in the serious
issues such as the cost of living crisis
why not should we vote for you that's
the attitude on the doorstep at the
moment and unless things change then
these elections are going to be really
quite tricky for those that have them
barry what do you want the prime
minister to say at prime minister's
questions today what what tack do you
think he needs to take well i think
there's very little he can actually say
at prime minister's questions he'll try
and give a robust uh defense of the
present situation but really
medium term we need to be thinking of
some policy changes
the national insurance increase in april
needs to be abandoned that's going to
put people on 25 000 pounds a year
paying a third of their income in tax
far too much so there has to be a change
in that to show that the conservative
government is in charge and is putting
people's economic best interests to the
fore
and that will help to steady down public
opinion and get more conservatives
coming back to the courts thank you and
claire very briefly we've only got 30
seconds but what what do you want to
hear from the prime minister today
what's what's going to turn around
people in your area
i'm to be honest i don't think there's
much that he can say at the moment uh
that would make the anger go away and we
really do need to see this report being
published in full as soon as possible
okay really clear uh claire pearsall and
barry leg thank you both very much
hopefully speak to you a little later as
well thanks so much
it's twelve o'clock you're watching sky
news prime minister's questions due to
start any moment we have our deputy
political editor sam coats here in the
studio in westminster with us uh it's
gonna be interesting isn't it there are
three enormous questions at the heart of
british politics right now we might find
out the answers in prime minister's
questions one does boris johnson receive
the sugray report two when will we see
the sugree report and three boris
johnson try to redact or not publish it
in full we hope we might get some of
those answers in the next 30 minutes
and
do we know whether he actually has seen
this report yet we don't think so
about 10 minutes ago he hadn't
seen it they need about three or four
hours i think from the moment it drops
to getting into the house of commons
there will be an
enormous amount
attempt by allies of boris johnson to
write the story of what the report
really says in their eyes before we can
almost look at
what sugray wrote herself he will be at
the dispatch box as soon as possible
that's why this could still come later
today although with every minute that
ticks by without downing street saying
that they've received it it becomes
slightly less likely and it's not clear
that it can be published when the house
is almost empty tomorrow uh so maybe it
gets late on monday
is that that feasible after the the
amount of interest that there is in it
surely if if the prime minister gets it
today there will be leaks between now
and monday
quite possibly and it might downing
street might gain that it's in their
interest to hold it off and then leak
favorable bits in the meantime look this
is all speculation we don't know
but we don't know why there's a delay
the report's almost ready it is for
sugray to determine the timing but for
boris johnson to determine
what is going to be published is sue
grey holding back because boris johnson
is wavering about what he
what he's going to publish he previously
promised to publish it all um sue gray
wants him to publish it all the police
think he can publish it all but is there
still any question about exactly what
can go in the public domain that's one
of the few things that i can think of
that might be
delaying the fact that this thing that
is all but ready uh uh he doesn't when
we're just hearing nothing about it's
odd cabinet ministers think it's odd
tory mps think it's odd and their
discomfort is growing by the moment and
in terms of the police investigation we
thought that that initially yesterday we
thought that was going to delay the sue
grey report but but it's been made clear
by her that um
you know you can't prejudice the police
investigation
she's given them the information that's
relevant to them the rest of us should
find out the rest that was all very
wrong yesterday to be honest jane uh
there was a period where downing street
was telling us oh no the secret report
can't come out to the police inquiry and
the police said yes it can
um we're not quite sure how they came to
that conclusion and it was all reversed
shortly afterwards somewhere in
whitehall they're not keen on this
coming out in a speedy fashion and it's
not entirely clear to me why we can all
make up our own minds but we're doing so
without full facts maybe kierstama with
his loyal abilities can get some
information out of the prime minister
those cheers would suggest boris johnson
just walking in and taking his place uh
at the dispatch box a pretty full
chamber
how much support will there be or might
there be another david davis moment like
there was last week when he said for the
sake of god go
we don't know i mean it is it is a full
chamber isn't it um should we listen in
and hear what the speaker's saying
mr speaker is my right honourable friend
the secretary of state for northern
ireland remarked to the house earlier
this morning this sunday marks a tragic
day in our history this was one of the
darkest days of the troubles
and i that's the 50th anniversary of
bloody sunday and i echo his call to
learn from the past to reconcile and
build a shared peaceful and prosperous
future mr speaker this morning i had
meetings with ministerial colleagues and
others
in addition to my duties in this house
i shall have further such meetings later
today
i associate my remarks with the prime
minister on bloody sunday
did the prime minister agree to the
chancellor of the exchequer writing off
4.3 billion pounds of fraud that's
154 pounds of every household in the
country
that went directly into the pockets of
fraudsters
no of course not mr speaker uh about
what i can well i can tell him
we we take we do not support uh
fraudulent or those who steal from the
public past mr speaker uh but what i can
tell what i can tell her is that
everybody in this country should be very
proud of the the huge effort that was
made
by lord agnew and others to secure
ventilators and to secure ppe and at the
time captain hindsight and others were
calling but calling for us to go faster
mr speaker
thank you uh mr speaker my local
hospital with george eliot has recently
issued all of its staff helpers and
volunteers with a medal in recognition
of the work that they've done and
continue to do through the covert
pandemic
would the prime minister join me in
thanking them all for the incredible
work they've done including the
specialist teams such as palliative care
who've had to act as surrogate families
for patients who've relatives who've
been able to when they're
able to attend because of restrictions
and will he consider following their
lead in issuing a national service medal
for all of our key workers who've done
such an outstanding job in keeping our
country going through the pandemic
prime minister yes of course mr speaker
i thank my uh honorable friend and i i'm
pleased that so many of the volunteers
that and the staff at uh george eliot
hospital have been uh recognized in the
uh queen's new year's honestly i've seen
the the medal that they uh are proposing
and i think it's it's lovely uh mr
speaker as i've told the house before uh
we're establishing a uk commission on
covid commemoration uh to consider how
we can uh commemorate everything that
we've all been through and the
commission will also consider how we can
recognize the courage of frontline
workers we now come through the leader
of the opposition kia stammer
thank you mr speaker and can i join with
the prime minister and his comments in
relation to bloody sunday
the minister of code
says that ministers who knowingly
mislead parliament will be expected to
offer their resignation
does the prime minister believe that
applies to him
prime minister mr speaker of course but
let me tell the house uh that i think
he's inviting a question about uh an
investigation which is uh you know mr
speaker i can't uh comment and uh uh
which i which he is as a lawyer mr
speaker will know that i that i can't
comment on and what i am focused on is
delivering the fastest recovery of any
european uh
of any uh european economy uh from covid
uh the uh the fastest booster rollout
400 000 more people on the payrolls now
than there were before the pandemic
began and we're launching a policy
tomorrow mr speaker he talks about he
talks about people being out of work uh
in my case uh that's for you and i
understand why he wants it we're
launching a plan tomorrow mr speaker to
get half a million people off welfare
into work it's a fantastic idea i hope
he supports
i it the prime minister said yes he
agrees the code does apply to him
uh and therefore if he misled parliament
he must resign
on the 1st of december the prime
minister told this house in relation to
parties during lockdown all guidance was
followed completely in number 10 from
that dispatch box
on the 8th of december looks critical he
said it on the 8th of december the prime
minister told this house i have been
repeatedly assured since these
allegations emerged there was no party
so since he acknowledges the minister of
code applies to him will he now resign
no mr speaker uh but you know
since he asks since he asked
since he asks about about covid
restrictions uh let me just remind the
house and indeed remind uh the country
that he has been relentlessly
opportunistic
he has he has he has flip flop he has
flip-flopped from one side uh to the
other uh he would have kept us he would
have kept us in lockdown in the summer
mr speaker he would have taken us back
into lockdown uh christmas mr speaker
and it's precisely because we didn't
listen to captain hindsight
that we have the fastest growing economy
in the g7 mr speaker and we have got all
the big calls right
[Applause]
the guy that said in hindsight he now
appreciates it was a party
we've discovered the real captain
hindsight haven't we mr speaker
yet let me spell out this let me spell
out they shout now they're gonna have to
go out and defend some of this nonsense
let me spell out the significance of
yesterday's developments
sue
[Music]
sue grey
mata to the police having found evidence
of behavior that's potentially a
criminal offence
prime minister if you do not understand
the significance of what happened
yesterday then i really do despair
because the police
having
[Applause]
prime minister the police having got
that material from sue gray
subjected to a test to decide whether to
investigate and that test was whether it
was the most serious and flagrant type
of breach in the rules
the police spelt out that what they
meant by that that those involved knew
or ought to have known what they were
doing was an offense
and that there was little ambiguity
about the absence of any reasonable food
just the prime minister
just
[Applause]
unfortunately you might not believe this
but our constituents are very interested
in both the questions and the answers if
some members do not wish to hear it
please leave quietly
here
mr speaker having got the material from
sue gray the police had to take a
decision
as to whether what they had before them
was the most serious and flagrant types
of breach of the rules if members want
to laugh at that
laugh
the police spelt out the police felt out
what they meant
they decided on the material they've
already got that they've already got
that those involved knew or ought to
have known what they were doing was an
offense
and that there was little ambiguity
around the absence of any reasonable
defense does the prime minister really
not understand the damage his behavior
is doing to our country
mr speaker i hope that the right
honourable gentleman understands uh that
although the issue that he raises uh is
important uh there is simply no way as
he knows as a lawyer that i can comment
on uh the investigation that he is
currently is currently taking place but
what i ca but what he also knows he
talks about the most serious issue he
talks about the most serious issue
before uh the public today and before
the world today it's almost as though he
was in ignorance of the fact uh mr
speaker that we have a crisis on the
borders of ukraine
i can tell him i can tell him what is
actually what is going on in the cabinet
room of this country is that the uk
government know mr speaker the uk
government is bringing the west
[Applause]
led together this government and this
prime minister and our foreign secretary
and defense secretary to bring the west
together to have the toughest possible
package of sanctions to deter president
putin from what i think would be a
reckless and a catastrophic invasion
that is what this government is doing
we're getting on with the job and i
think he needs to raise his game frankly
[Applause]
can i just say honestly
can i just say to both sides oh
constitution watching it tensions are
running high and what we need to be able
to do is allow the people out there who
are bothered about their futures to hear
what is said
on both sides so please let's give the
respect our constituents deserve here
mr speaker this was the prime minister
who went into hiding for five days
because of these allegations
talk talk to me about being around for
the allegations
[Applause]
mr speaker
[Music]
can i just say i don't want to do this
but i am determined to make sure our
constituents can hear the next person
that stops me hearing will not be
continuing in this debate
questions mr speaker the prime
minister's continual defenses wait for
the sue grey report
on the 8th of december he told this
house i will place a copy of the report
in the library of the house of commons
his spokesperson has repeatedly stated
that means the full report
not parts of the report not a summary of
the report not an edited copy
so can the prime minister confirm that
he will publish the full sue grey report
as he receives it
mr speaker what i can tell him is that
we've got to leave the report to the
independent uh investigators he knows uh
and of course uh when i receive it of
course i will do exactly uh what i said
but i can i can tell him that in the
meantime i think what the people of this
country want to hear is what we're doing
uh to what we're doing to tackle the
issues that matter to all of us fixing
fixing the cost of living mr speaker
helping people across across the country
by lifting the living wage mr speaker by
helping people with their fuel costs mr
speaker as this government is and by
cutting the tax of people on universal
credit cutting the tax by a thousand
pounds and mr speaker that party
opposite are committed to abolishing
universal credit that's their policy
stammer
[Music]
cutting the tax
[Laughter]
the police say the evidence as
meets the test frankly the public have
made up their minds they know he's not
fit for the job and that's what really
matters here throughout this scandal the
tourists have done immense damage to
public trust when the leader of the
scottish conservative said the prime
minister should resign the leader of the
house called him a lightweight
english
english conservatives publicly
undermining the union by trading
scotland with utter disdain
how much damage are the prime minister's
cabinet prepared to do to save his skin
minister
uh well mr speaker i think that he was
uh offering a yet more general criticism
of uh what's been going on in downing
street let me just remind the house
what's been going on in in dining street
uh we've been prioritizing the covid
backlogs uh mr speaker investing
investing massively in nine million more
scans uh so that people get the
treatment that they need and that
they've been waiting for and making sure
that we have 44 000 more people in our
reddit yes
he says it's rubbish they didn't vote
for it mr speaker they don't support it
44 000 more people in our nhs now than
there were
in 2020
and and we're fixing social care mr
speaker which which governments have
neglected for decades and labor did
absolutely they have no plan at all to
fix the nhs or to fix social care vote
labour wait longer
[Applause]
the reality is that we now have the
shameful spectacle of a prime minister
of the united kingdom being subject to a
police investigation
unable to leave the country
incapable of doing the right thing
and every day his cabinet failed to
speak out they become more and more
complicit
and what's utterly damning
despite the huff and puff is that this
is all happening when petrol prices the
weekly shop and energy bills are going
through the roof three months ago
labor suggested cutting v80 from energy
bills still the government has failed to
act
instead of getting on with their jobs
they're wheeled out to save his
whatever he says in his statement later
today or tomorrow won't change the facts
isn't this a prime minister and a
government that have shown nothing but
contempt for the decency honesty and
respect that define this country
no mr speaker
we love this country and we're doing
everything in our power to help this
country
and and of course of course he wants me
out of the way mr speaker of course that
of course he wants me out of the way uh
he does and i i can't and many people of
course of course i i don't deny it uh
for all sorts of reasons many people may
want me out of the way but i tell you
the reason he wants me out of the way is
because he knows that this government
can be trusted to
[Applause]
and we deliver on brexit mr speaker he
voted 48 times he voted 48 times to take
this country back into the european
union we deliver we do he can't be trump
we vote we deliver the fastest vaccine
rollout in europe mr speaker and we will
deliver on our plan to unite and level
up across the whole of the uk prime down
10 mr speaker job vacancies at a record
high colossal investment
yes mr speaker we're delivering and they
have no plan three times as much tech
investment as france in this country
twice as much as germany we have a
vision for this country as the most as
the most prosperous and successful
economy in europe because we are going
to unite and level up the problem with
the labour party today mr speaker is
that he's a lawyer
not a leader
we've taken
we've taken the tough decisions
[Applause]
i can't see what the prime minister's
got to say no
i would have thought i would have
thought is the prime minister
of this side of the house i'm surprised
that this side the hostels want to
listen to it because i do prime minister
well mr speaker i only wanted to add the
point that we've taken the tough
decisions we've got the big calls right
and we're and in particular i am getting
on with the job
thank you mr speaker include south the
welsh government has been dragging its
feet on urgent repairs to the new bridge
road while in contrast the prime
minister and his government have
delivered record leveling up fund
investment of 13.3 million along the d
valley from the trevor basin to the
landline in church and on to corwin will
the prime minister comment on how the
next phase of the leveling up fund will
bring hope and prosperity to other
communities right across our proud union
of the united kingdom
prime minister i thank my honorable
friend very much and what pleasure it
gives me to address the member uh for
clew in south where i tried
unsuccessfully so many uh years ago and
i'm delighted that a conservative
government is now investing so massively
in leveling up uh including southern
across the whole of wales
we now come to the leader of the smp in
blackboard
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker and can i associate
myself with the remarks of the prime
minister on bloody sunday i'm sure mr
speaker you and the entire house will
want to commemorate tomorrow the
holocaust memorial day when six million
jews
lost their lives at the hands of the
regime of hitler and of course we
remember other genocides not least more
recently in bosnia and we all pray for
continued peace in that country
mr speaker
at the heart of this matter we have a
prime minister
who is being investigated
by the police
for breaking his own laws
absolutely unprecedented
a man who demeans the office
of prime minister this is the
latest in a rap sheet that is already a
mile long
illegally proroguing parliament
misleading the house
decorating with dodgy cash
partying while the public suffered
every moment he stays
he's dragging out the agony for families
who reminded her the sacrifices they
made and dragging his party further
through the dirt the public knows it the
house knows it even his own mps know it
when will the prime minister cop on and
go
[Applause]
well uh mr speaker i wanted to
join the uh right honourable gentleman
uh and echo his sentiments about about
holocaust memorial day uh where i think
he is uh completely right uh but i must
say that uh he made the same point last
week uh he's wrong then he's wrong now
uh much as i enjoy uh cooperating him um
precisely because i enjoy uh cooperating
with him so much and with all his uh
scottish colleagues that i have
absolutely no intention of doing what he
suggests
mr speaker every moment that the prime
minister lingers every nick in this
death by a thousand cuts is sucking
attention from the real issues facing
the public
tory cuts
brexit and the soaring cost of living
have pushed millions of families into
poverty the impending national insurance
tax hike hangs like a guillotine while
they eat cake
this is nothing short
of a crisis
and the only route out the only route to
restore public trust
is for the prime minister to go
how much longer
will 20 mps let this go on for
how much more damage
are they willing to do
and it's time to get this over with
show the prime minister the door
prime minister uh well mr speaker i i
don't know where who's been eating more
cake uh
what i was saying to them what i would
say to the uh to the right honourable
gentlemen for whom actually mr speaker i
have a i have a behind the scenes people
don't get this but actually uh we
cooperate well and i want to continue uh
to do so jesse norman
uh thank you mr speaker as the prime
minister will know from personal
experience
the river y is one of the most beautiful
rivers in europe yet it's
fragile ecosystem is being destroyed by
phosphate and other pollution
the river crosses the border between
england and wales but so far it has
proven impossible to get the environment
agency natural england and natural
resources wales even to begin planning a
single integrated long-term strategy to
clean up the river will the prime
minister press those agencies now and
the welsh government at last to come to
the table and will he ask ministers to
look at the idea of a new ring fenced
national rivers recovery fund using
fines paid by the water companies so we
can clean the y and other rivers out
properly once and for all
well uh mr speaker i i had a memorable
swim in the wire myself i think at about
five o'clock in the morning once and it
tasted absolutely tasty as
like like nectar
but
i i understand the problem that he
raises it's very important that our
beautiful uh rivers should be clean as
well and my honourable friend the
environment minister will be visiting
the y area uh shortly with or without
his uh swimming trunks and uh i know
that we're urging uh the welsh
government to take this matter as
seriously as this government is please
get him in there
so jeffrey doubles thank you mr speaker
the prime minister will know that many
families across the united kingdom are
struggling with the increased cost of
living and rising energy costs but in
northern ireland that is compounded by
the protocol 27 is the increase in the
cost of bringing goods from great
britain to northern ireland when we can
get access to those goods it is costing
business 2.5 million pounds every day
almost a billion pounds a year the cost
of the protocol the prime minister talks
about uniting this nation and leveling
up
he could do that by removing the rsc
border and restoring northern ireland's
place fully within the uk internal
market
prime minister speaker i must say that i
support passionately the uh indignation
of the right honourable gentleman
opposite and and and yes uh yes mr
speaker uh
i never thought uh when we negotiated
that this would be uh with 200
businesses 200 businesses who have
stopped supplying northern ireland foods
are being blocked mr speaker christmas
cards are being surcharged and frankly
mr speaker the eu is implementing this
in an insane and petty fogging way
and we need to sort it out and i
completely support what he's saying
hello
as my right honourable friend the prime
minister seen the report
published earlier this month by the eac
making recommendations about what else
should be done in addition to the
welcome measures in the environment act
to clean up our rivers including the
river y but all our rivers one of the
recommendations was that defra should
give guidance to off-what to require
water companies to invest much more in
water treatment in the next round of
capital spending approvals will he
encourage his secretary of state to give
this guidance in the strategic policy
statement to off what expected shortly
prime minister uh
thank you very much yes mr speaker my my
right or friend is completely right i
welcome the report by uh his committee
this government is going uh further and
faster than uh any other government uh
hitherto uh to uh protect and improve
the health of our rivers and seize
lloyd russell
thank you mr speaker
happy unbirthday to him happy unbirthday
to him because just like the mad hatter
he didn't need the excuse of a birthday
to have a party but it did help didn't
it so when he had groups of people
singing to him when illegal um
gatherings in door were illegal and
communal singing was banned my
constituents think that he has lied my
constituents think that he lied to this
house and my constituents think he lied
to them when he was partying and telling
them all
[Music]
in passing what your constituents said
but you can't continue to labor that one
point
by russell
so
i would prefer to be led by a lawyer
than a liar will he now resign
[Applause]
your member will be withdrawing that
last comment i withdraw it that's what
my constituency not like right two
lesson but prime minister
well i i i think that the honourable
gentleman i'm afraid in everything he
said just now plainly doesn't know what
he is talking about you plainly doesn't
know what he's talking about but i but
what and like what i can tell him and
what i can tell his uh constituents is
that irrespective of what they want to
focus on and i understand why they do mr
speaker this government is going to get
on with the job and deliver for the
people of this country
the speaker the great people of cornwall
voted in our prime minister on a promise
of to get brexit done it was successful
faced with the global pandemic our prime
minister set out to build a
world-beating
vaccination program to save lives mr
speaker he was successful he's now
lifted covered restrictions against huge
pressure not to do so and he's got the
economy back on track
can i ask my right honourable friend the
prime minister
will he continue to deliver and on the
priorities of my constituents
and the millions across this country who
voted for him in 2019
mr speaker i i really can't improve on
the the brilliant question uh the people
that the people of southeast cornwall
are lucky to have uh
such a representative and she's right in
what she says jonathan edwards
uh mr speaker tomorrow is the second
anniversary since my constituent michael
leary was murdered and his body
desecrated in an attempt to cover up the
crime
will he meet with campaigners and myself
to discuss the need for a new offense or
amended sentencing guidelines to reflect
the extra suffering faced by the
families of murdered victims whose
bodies were concealed or desecrated
prime minister well i thank you very
much for drawing this appalling case to
the attention of the of the house and i
can certainly uh assure him that he will
be getting the uh the meeting he needs
at the earliest opportunity so mike
penny thank you very much mr speaker on
the 24th of november mr speaker i asked
the prime minister if he would meet with
me and
my constituents about the future or lack
of future of a new hospital in hamilt
hampstead i thought when i put in the
question today that i'd have to ask the
same question but last night i was
offered to meet him
so magic so on another note prime
minister
many children in this country are
suffering from a special form of seizure
which medical cannabis prescribed by a
consultant actually helps them live only
two children in this country get that
free on the nhs the rest of those
children have to beg bogger and scrape
and their families to try and get that
prescription issued by a consultant paid
for can the prime minister please use
the political will i know the secretary
of state has the political will but
please push this forward so these
children live
i thank my uh honourable friend
delighted he has the meeting that uh
that he wanted uh we've already changed
the law to doctors to prescribe cannabis
products where clinically uh appropriate
but mr speaker uh i'm we're very keen to
support it provided uh the mhra is happy
as well
thank you thank you mr speaker threats
and intimidation bribery and blackmail
racism and islamophobia that's the
character of his government every day
the prime minister lurches from scandal
to scandal and meanwhile his government
has written off 4.3 billion pounds to
fraudsters instead of writing off loans
to fraudsters
why won't the prime minister write his
resignation to the queen
[Applause]
mr speaker
because let me just she talks about
racism and uh and islamophobia you look
at look at this government mr speaker
look if you want if you look at look at
the modern conservative party we are the
party of hope and opportunity for people
across this country
irrespective of race or religion and we
don't care what religion uh you affirm
all we care about is whether you're
interested in ideas of aspiration and
opportunity that's what we're about
the recruitment of 20 000 police
officers is a fantastic commitment to
law and order by this government
bedfordshire in common with many other
police forces has lost out on about 95
officers as a result of the imposition
of damping in 2004
so we don't have to rely on one-off
special grants to stay solvent will the
prime minister recommit to the
reformation of the police funding
formula in this parliament
prime minister my right old friend the
policing minister has assured me we're
going to be introducing a new funding
formula before the end of the parliament
but i'm pleased that bedford bedford
police have already recruited 100 100
additional officers as part of our
uplift program that's part of the 11 000
more that this government has put on the
streets
thank you mr speaker twice in recent
months i've asked the pm about his and
his transport secretary commitment to
deliver the pm's pledge to invest in uk
built zeb's zero mission buses i did not
receive a clear answer worrying reports
in the media of treasury cuts to bus
buying plans highlight a conflict
between the pm and his chancellor prime
minister as the current chancellor
denying you the current prime minister
the right to fulfill your pledge to buy
four thousand zero emission buses
mr speaker i don't there's never in the
history of this country been such a
bonanza for buses uh i am personally a
bus uh fanatic we're putting five
billion pounds into into buses over and
cycling during this parliament and 355
million into of new funding for zero
emission buses and yes of course we want
to see the benefits of that funding
spread right across the whole of the
united kingdom
[Music]
mr speaker securing extra health
services at queen mary's hospital sidcup
is a key priority for local residents as
it is for me as the first homegrown mp
for old bexley
will the prime minister support me in
delivering this extra investment for our
local hospital and join me in thanking
all of the staff at queen mary's for
their incredible efforts
yes and i can't say what a joy it is to
welcome my honorable friends at his
place joy seems a bit confined but
confined on the ventures office mr
speaker uh i thank him for his work
and support for everybody at queen
mary's hospital which uh he and i
campaign have campaigned for for many
years uh last year queen mary's received
eight hundred thousand pounds of funding
and i hope that it will benefit further
uh from the one million funding awarded
to the oxley's nhs foundation trust to
improve uh technology services across
its estates richard bergen thank you mr
speaker
a nurse a nurse who organized a small
socially distanced demonstration against
this government's pay cuts was fined ten
thousand pounds people out there are
seek to the back teeth of it being one
rule for the tories and another for
everyone else the prime minister for
once needs to do a decent thing for
god's sake resign yeah
i don't think there was a question there
uh there was there was an invitation uh
for me to do what of course the labour
party uh wants me to do but i'm not
gonna do it mrs because we are gonna
carry on with our agenda of uniting and
leveling up across the country
and they fundamentally know that they
have no answer to that we have a plan
and a vision for this country they have
absolutely nothing to say and that is
the difference between our side and
their side
[Music]
mr speaker alongside the threats of a
russian invasion of ukraine there are
real fears of china invading taiwan on
sunday beijing staged the largest
incursion into taiwan's airspace since
october
does my right honourable friend agree
with me that military aggression and
threat of occupation are never
acceptable anywhere in the world
and will he confirm that under this
conservative government the uk will
always be at the forefront of standing
up forcefully for freedom and democracy
security and stability
i thank my honourable friend i want to
tell him that the the chinese military
fights that have taken place near taiwan
in recent days and months are not
conducive to peace and stability in the
region and what we need is a peaceful
and constructive dialogue by people on
both sides of the taiwan strait and i
know that that is what my right
honourable friend the foreign secretary
and uh and all colleagues are working
for
that ends playing ministers questions
for those who are not staying for the uq
please leave quietly
well at the end of prime minister's
questions kirsten there uh putting uh
quite a few times to boss johnson about
the sue grey report wanting to know if
that report would be published in full
uh but we did manage to glean from prime
minister's questions when it might be
published or indeed whether boris
johnson had seen it or deputy political
editor sam coats is with me now uh
compared to last
week's pr premises questions it was a
little bit flatter wasn't it um could
could kierstarma have given it a bit
more welly do you think oh jane i mean
there are just occasions where prime
minister's questions doesn't quite raise
to the occasion
uh going into prime minister's questions
there were i think there were three big
issues that we wanted to know the answer
to one is has boris johnson got the su
grey report well nobody asked him two is
will boris johnson publish it in full
well kirsten summer asked that once and
to my year he gave us somewhat ambiguous
answer i don't know whether we've got it
for you to listen to here but uh i
believe this is what uh happened when
boris johnson was asked are you going to
publish it in full
thank you very much mr speaker i thank
my honourable friend for this question
don't think we have that clip anyway
well let me uh
[Laughter]
are you going to promise it in full and
he said when i receive it of course i
will do what i said and that obviously
leaves some wiggle room uh because that
depends what boston means when he said i
i'm gonna do what i said what is he
referring back to what it wasn't was a
clean commitment from the prime minister
uh where he said as i have said before i
will put the full report in the house of
commons library we understand from
sources this appears to be a live issue
in play and anything other than an
absolutely unambiguous question answer
to that question is always going to rise
um uh eyebrows and i think that's
exactly what the prime minister has done
the third thing
is that uh boris johnson uh could have
said when the sugree report is going to
emerge into the public domain and we
didn't have a commitment on that either
so somewhat
underwhelming uh in terms of just the
raw facts of it interesting kirsten
didn't sort of come back uh and
particularly press on that question of
of the full report being released it
might be that in a few minutes time
downing street come out and say what
boris johnson meant was yes of course
it's all going to be in the house comes
library so it's up to boris johnson's
aides to perhaps uh to perhaps clarify
that uh but um whilst there was some
heat enlightened boys um johnson was
pressed by kierstarma about the fact
that he has now admitted to being at a
gathering uh that was for his birthday
uh when he told the house of commons
that no birthday parties uh no parties
took place in downing street uh and that
would appear to breach what would
contradict what he told he borrowed
johnson told the house of commons a few
weeks ago that there were no parties and
he gave a commitment that ministers who
mislead the house of commons should
resign that was the sort of uh
kirsten's prestige his sort of trick in
this prime minister's questions but we
didn't really get very far boris johnson
just sort of stoneballed him on that
question uh and uh and we didn't get
much further forward i mean do you think
it's partly because we are expecting the
seagra report it might come out this
afternoon and in a sense that will be
the opportunity that kiersten will have
to really go at the prime minister maybe
but this is a prime time slot who wants
to give up prime time real estate on tv
then when everybody's watching and and
because we just don't know when the
report's coming out
uh it might be pierced army's only
opportunity today to you know appear in
the headlines appear and then appear in
the light so you don't you don't know
um uh
actually there was one other answer in
prime minister's questions that was
quite interesting and it was the very
first answer to kate ossimore now she's
a labour mp and she's asked about this
massive write-off of fraud loans
that is 4.3 billion pounds is so big
that it prompted the resignation of the
conservative minister in the house of
lords on monday at the dispatch box who
said that white was handling the whole
thing with such disgrace he was off kate
osama asked boris johnson whether or not
he had uh signed off on that policy
agreed with the chancellor that that
should be the case
and he said of course not well that
would appear at first glance to be
rather jumping dumping the chancellor
richie sunak in it if he didn't know
about it
um so i think labour are already quite
hot on that issue
so i think overall there was a lot of
heat and light but we didn't really
advance very a great deal of
understanding through that premises
questions okay sam thanks very much for
that for your analysis uh so what do
some members of the prime minister's
party think about what they've just seen
well we spoke to claire pearcel a former
conservative adviser and currently a
conservative councillor before we also
spoke to barry legg a former tory mp
we're also joined this time by dominic
samuels uh former and most recent
president of the orthodox conservatives
who's also an activist for the party
thanks all very much for joining us
let's go back to claire and barry first
just to get your thoughts claire you
said that you didn't think there was
much that he could do to sway voters
it wasn't an especially vintage boris
performance was it
no it wasn't uh he does appear to come
out fighting but we've not really moved
on pretty pretty much from where we were
and it was a little bit flat on the
question of will it be published as i
think sam has just alluded to there
wasn't a straight answer he's just given
himself a lot of wiggle room to either
only put out a summary or a redacted
version so i think that needed to have
been pressed more and kyostama really
has
missed his opportunity to do so so yes i
think we were expecting a bit more um
but it's been a little bit of a letdown
barry leg you you were hoping you know
you saying the thing that we do need is
is are more policy changes in the
conservative party was it was it policy
heavy enough for you pmqs
yeah i think i think there were some
interesting uh signposts on policy
overall i thought it was a strong
competitive performance by the prime
minister and sam is right the leader in
our opposition really didn't hit home
uh on the issue of taxes a very
interesting question from ian blackford
of the scottish nationalists he said the
national insurance
increases which i was referring to in my
earlier comments
were like a guillotine hanging over the
conservative party and certainly the
prime minister didn't disagree with him
uh i think there was a realism from the
prime minister that he's going to have
to make changes on the tax front
otherwise he's going to become quite
unpopular there was also a very
interesting question from yeah jeffrey
donaldson the leader of the dup
in which he put
uh
in which he spoke about the terrible
defects in the northern ireland project
which of course boris johnson had given
the ok to
when we left the eu and in fact the
prime minister then said i agree with
everything that mr danson said in way of
criticism
of the northern ireland protocol now
that's that's a very encouraging sign
for people that believe in the union
because that matter is still up uh for
discussion uh with the eu at the moment
and uh boris johnson is sending his
foreign secretary this trust and it
sounds as if he's sending her with a
stronger brief than many anticipated so
under the circumstances i think it was a
quite a credible uh performance by boris
johnson and another poor day uh for the
leader of the opposition okay let's
bring in dominique samuels and uh former
president of orthodox conservatives um
what were you hoping from pmq's today
and did it did it serve up what you were
hoping for
no unfortunately and you know i've been
boris johnson's staunchest critic
throughout the pandemic because i've
been very lately against um a lot of the
restrictions and the government's
approach to it i've not thought it was
very conservative hence why you know i
don't plan to vote for the conservatives
ever again but one thing that i wanted
is i wanted the prime minister to focus
on carrying on with the job because
there aren't many alternatives at the
moment within the conservative party and
a lot of his own mps know that so i
really wanted him to sort of have more
of a staunch defense but as the
allegations about parties and now on
including a birthday cake keep rolling
in the prime minister's defense of this
gets weaker and weaker now the only
thing he can do is refer to the upcoming
report by sue gray and i think the fear
is as more and more mps are challenging
the prime minister to resign his own mps
will get quite angsty about this and
think we can't get along with you know
running the country because more people
are concerned about the prime minister's
private life and how he broke his own
rule so that is difficult but i think
overall
boris johnson is a far better leader
than kiss dahmer i think you know that's
just the top and bottom of it so
it is precarious right now but there are
bigger issues like national insurance
like tax rises like the energy crisis
that we should be focused on as a
country and not birthday cakes and
parties in my view
and dominique in terms of where the
party could move forward from this a
culture change seems to be
what i'm hearing from all of you
about about the leadership is it is it
possible do you think for boris johnson
to do that to be the man who spearheads
a culture change and rehabilitate
himself and those around him
i think he's gonna have to be because a
lot of the chaos that's ensued
throughout darling street has occurred
under his nose and it's not just because
of the parties it's you know it's
dominic dominic cummings it's owen
patterson it's all of those issues and
it's something the prime minister needs
to sort out i think he's got a very
short time frame to do this but at the
end of the day whether he survives or
not in the coming months um he won't be
prime minister for much longer i don't
think
okay really pretty damning dominique
samuels barry legg and claire pierce
thank you all so much for for joining us
and for giving us your thoughts before
and after pmq's thank you
right well that's what some tory voters
past tory voters at least in one of
their cases think what about what the
politicians think let's go down to the
house of commons our political
correspondent kate mccann is in central
lobby in parliament kate
hi there jane yes i'm joined by jonathan
gullis a conservative mp who's always
been fairly supportive i think with the
prime minister boris johnson so what do
you make of that performance today he
really needed a good one was it enough i
thought the prime minister was on fine
form once again talking about the issues
that mattered to people in places like
represented stoke-on-trent north
kidsgrove and torque whether that be
about the cost of living whether about
be what's happening in ukraine and also
about delivering on leveling up and
those are things that people are telling
me when i was in small thorn community
center last week or in the bull's head
in berlin saying that they wanted to
hear this government and as members of
parliament cracking on and discussing i
think it's fair to say lots of people
would like to hear the government
talking about other issues not just the
parties that allegedly took place in
downing street but almost half with
pmq's today were questions about exactly
that so we can't move on while this
hangs over the government well what we
can't move on because captain hindsight
is relentless in talking about the
issues that he thinks matters but
actually if he got out of the london
bubble and when he spoke to people in
places like stoke-on-trent he realized
that they're more interested in the
things like listed earlier let's not
forget there's a conservative government
and this prime minister has delivered 56
million for the leveling up fund 29
million for transforming cities fund 550
brand new jobs for the home office and
the 17.6 million kids growth town deal
that's going to reopen kids grow sports
centre that was closed under the labour
administration in the local council at
that time because ultimately that's what
people want to see that's what they want
us to spend my time on when i'm down in
westminster and that's what i'm focused
on as is the prime minister so would you
say that you're happy with the way the
government is running things at the
moment i think the government is doing a
good job you know this was the most
challenging global pandemic we've seen
in over 100 years
unprecedented no country's got
everything perfect we've never tried to
pretend we got everything right but on
the big calls the prime ministers
absolutely hit the nail on the head
every single time and when you had
lieutenant lockdown and shadow home
secretary wanting to make sure that we
locked up this country yet again the
prime minister took the tough call over
the christmas break stuck to his
instincts and guess what happened we are
now on course to once for the second
time in a row be the fastest growing
country in the g7 but forgive me i asked
if you're happy so are you i am happy
indeed absolutely the prime minister's
got my absolute full support that's why
i'm proud to come on here and speak to
you today and say why i'm fully backing
him okay but many in your party can't
say the same they are frustrated they
call this situation a distraction we're
now worried about not getting the
supreme report potentially this week and
there's a police investigation hanging
over the prime minister too is there not
a little part of you that worries that
he cannot recover from this
i believe that when we get back on to
focusing on the issues that matter and
that's what the prime minister is doing
day in day out whether that be looking
at taking some of the toughest possible
sanctions by leading the west on
tackling
president putin and looking at russian
aggression on the ukrainian border
whether that be delivering on the
leveling up agenda whether that be
coming up with a plan with the
chancellor to tackle obviously rising
energy prices then we are doing that
work it's just a shame it's not getting
heard through the mainstream media and
that's because partly because labour
party are obsessed they fear the prime
minister because they know that when
it's captain hindsight versus boris
johnson in the general election boris
johnson is going to win i firmly believe
that and i think ultimately what we need
to do is to spend less time focusing on
uh stuff like that and more time
focusing on what really matters against
the constituents that i serve and others
serve well tell you what let's focus on
something else then because while pm's
was happening we've seen evidence from
an official foreign office email address
that at the time of the
the evacuation of afghanistan there is
evidence that the prime minister
approved the evacuation of animals and
people working for a charity it was in
the media a lot of the time boris
johnson was repeatedly asked whether he
had personally intervened he repeatedly
denied it in fact he called those claims
nonsense so did he lie
well this is the first time hearing of
it i've been in the chamber and come out
just a short time ago so unfortunately
i'm gonna be able to comment on that i'm
sure the foreign affairs select
committee will be examining that more
detail but i refer i suppose the
comments that you stated earlier which
is the prime minister denied any
personal involvement okay but these are
emails from an official foreign office
source they have been released as part
of a committee investigation i'm aware
that you haven't seen them in full and
that's fair enough but does this go to
those questions about a culture at the
top of the very government where the
prime minister denies that things have
taken place but later it appears that
they have i think that this prime
minister has inherited a brexit
situation where he had to work
incredibly hard to deliver on brexit the
prime minister has then gone through a
global pandemic and managed to get
through the prime minister's gone
through a global pandemic made some very
tough calls he's then had to deal with a
really terrible situation in afghanistan
i'm affected by that personally a person
i knew growing up in the town of
stratford-upon-avon lost his life out
there serving for armed forces and so
you know it's an emotional topic for me
as you can understand but you'll also
appreciate that i'm not going to comment
on something i've not read and i don't
think that would be appropriate to
either no that's fair enough when i've
said that but let's talk more about the
culture i'm asking you more generally
now does this underline those questions
that some in your own party are now
asking about whether the prime minister
is setting the right tone at the very
top of government the prime minister is
setting the right tone this is a prime
minister who has made the tough calls
during the global pandemic and has got
them right every single time this is a
prime minister who told the nation he
wanted to level up places like
stoke-on-trent north carolina talk that
had 70 years of neglect by lazy labour
mps labour lazy lazy labour councils
because simply they had no aspiration
for the communities that i serve i spend
every single day fighting for those
people the prime minister hears those
calls that's why he's delivered over now
over 150 or million pounds in capital
infrastructure and we're hoping to see
more on the revenue side of things
through the share prosperity fund and
hopefully busting back better which we
were actually in number 10 discussing
with him just yesterday so ultimately
this is a prime minister that
understands what we're doing understand
what the people of stoke-on-trent north
korea's government want us to be doing
and they're taking on obviously uh the
blob as we i would call it making sure
we're standing up for our country
standing up on the world stage and
uniting our western allies dealing with
russian aggression on the ukrainian
border is there anything the prime
minister could do or could have been
found to have done that would change
your mind i think the prime minister is
a fantastic individual someone that i
can say is delivered time and again for
my constituents and i'm very proud to be
working alongside of him jonathan
gullitz thank you so much for joining us
this afternoon thank you there were many
more conservative mps in the house of
commons today many of whom were
expecting the prime minister to be
pretty robust i think it's fair to say
he was in parts but there are some and
they have walked up pretty quickly
behind us not keen to talk to the
cameras this afternoon who feel like
potentially he hasn't done enough
okay kate thanks very much well still
with us in our westminster studio deputy
political editor sam coats and sam cake
mentioned it there there's this email
regarding the pen farthing flight um
no comment from from that mp about it
but this is interesting isn't it and not
great news for the prime minister again
this is another development in the last
hour
now you might remember last august there
was the evacuation of kabul and there
was a question at the time about whether
or not priority
and if not priority help should be given
to an individual called penn farthing
around an animal charity in kabul
to help him and his animals come to the
uk
now to cut a long story short at the
time boris johnson denied involvement
but in the last hour the foreign affairs
select committee chair by tom toucan has
published an email from zach goldsmith
who's close both to boris johnson and
his wife carrie carrie being a
well-known animal rights
activist and supporter on the 25th of
august and the key bit is uh that uh it
says this charity has received a lot of
publicity and the pm has just authorized
their staff and animals to be evacuated
uh and the charity are hoping to be
treated in the same capacity as
other people who needed to leave the
country but the key words there the pm
has just authorized their staff and
animals to be evacuated that was denied
at the time i think that there's gonna
be quite a lot of comment on that in the
hours and months ahead okay sam thanks
very much for that
well you are watching sky news live from
the heart of westminster today coming up
the prime minister continues to be under
pressure